hey guys I'm Bryce and ER and Ally and
AJ are here hi some news a movie out yep
leap away for now
you look great so yeah so yeah it does
it's also the kind of the most adult
we've seen the two of you probably it's
probably the most adult you've ever seen
us as a pair which is kind of cool yeah
so [ __ ] of you I'm a garrison of July
musics a big part of it too
yeah track she recorded by 78 violet are
present in the movie yes one of them is
we've now started actually focusing on
just making a record as a lean AJ and
just going back to we just had like our
roommates never like we're going back
and we're going back fine one song was
released a seventy at violet which is
great and I adore I love hothouse
that'll always be a part of us
sounds a bit haphazard but we really did
say like it's time to go back to our
roots and just embrace that this is a
way well I think there was also a moment
in in finding that new band name that we
were trying to kind of separate
ourselves from being children and seen
as being child's like performers right
um and that you know now we're writing
music as adults and that transition is
really hard are there any songs that you
never want to perform again like well
yeah never perform that song
no and it's so funny because n because
re it's funny that you can still write
something and you were a hundred percent
into it in the moment and I thought oh
I'm percent out now yes what isn't about
like whoa that is a no I don't like the
lyrics I don't like the way the chorus
moves
I just doesn't seem like us so what's
the sound of the new music I'd say it's
very indie rock and there's I definitely
pop sensibilities and pop lyrics but I
I'd say that all of our stuff is led
with death the lyrics are very important
to us it's not just a filler you know is
there like an expectation of what we can
hear any music at an album I mean I
think that it'll be early next year's
when is music to hear that simple